first say the Lib Dem leadership race is
turning into something of a stroll for
the one candidate who's thrown his hat
into the ring with contender after
contender stepping away from the fight
it now looks pretty certain that
serpents cable is going to pick up the
baton from Tim Farron later this year
and so Vince joins us now in the studio
hello good to see you here thank you
well the story in a lot of the papers
this morning is a suggestion that the
government may be rowing back from
austerity now of course you a member of
that coalition who pushed through many
of those belt tightening moves is now
the right time to loosen the belt
slightly well there certainly is a time
to change the emphasis of policy but I
mean I I just can't understand this
argument says you either have austerity
or non austerity I mean the world isn't
like that you have more or less of
something I think what there is a big
public mood for and I think is right is
that we shift the balance instead of
just cutting cutting public spending we
have people willing to pay more tax and
indeed my party campaigns the general
election saying and a penny and the
pound of income tax for the Health
Service and I think people are up for
that kind of change
similarly public sector pay I mean you
can't just have unlimited public sector
pay but we should be lifting public
sector pay above the present cap which
pushes people's it thing comes down in
real terms and you know again we argued
in the election for a phased increase
and so at least people's pay teachers
nurses is protected in real terms I do
would also argue that it makes sense to
use government's borrowing capacity at
very low interest rates to do more in
investment you know social housing
infrastructure these are the things that
we could do very sensibly with in some
public finance you mentioned a few
things there how about tuition fees
because there is a suggestion from
someone the Conservative Party that's an
area they could look at again labor have
said that they want to scrap tuition
fees is it just gonna be the Lib Dems
now backing the idea with 9 grand well I
think they're panicking I think we
certainly need to look at the way the
system's worked if you remember tuition
fees were introduced under the labor
government there was subsequent
increased under the coalition we need to
see how it's worked its panicking now
the governmental labor or he's
well the load party had been
ridiculously populist program which
doesn't really stand up to investigation
I mean if you don't have any form of
fees I mean who pay I mean know who pays
for universities and you know how do you
end this discrimination between the 40%
of students who go to university and who
would be subsidized as opposed to the
60% who don't and that would be highly
inequitable they're winning lot of votes
they want they if it is and that's why I
think we really need to look at it but
if we got more money for education and
I'd love to have more public money for
education the real pressure point at the
moment is in the schools and the skills
are horribly underfunding we're getting
teachers teacher assistants being laid
off I mean that's where the real
priority is at the moment yes by all
means let's look at universities but
university is about the only bit of the
publicly financed sector of the economy
which of which are flourishing and you
know for goodness sake with some cheap
populist gesture killing that off would
be a very dangerous and stupid thing to
do
okay strong words there for my use the
Vince on that now let's assume that you
are going to be the extant Lib Dem
leader well you are the only candidates
at the moment so before we get too
excited about it at the moment the Lib
Dems appear to have a huge part of that
policy being all about offering a second
referendum on the brexit deal mopping up
the votes of disgruntled remain is if
your leader are you gonna stick by that
it's not always been something you've
been wholly committed to shall we say
the idea of a binary referendum yes I am
committed to it I mean I'm not assuming
I'll be the leader we have a proper
process somebody else may come up and I
respect that but as you say no one else
is competing I mean I think we're we're
distinct in the Lib Dems and we're in
actually in a very strong position
politically is that we're the only party
at the moment which is campaigning
against this very very damaging extreme
hard exit brexit option which the
government is pursuing with the support
of Jeremy Corbyn I'm and that was
revealed very clearly in Parliament this
week and we will campaign very very
strongly together with some dissident
MPs from the Labour Party in the Tory
party and others to keep us within the
single market to keep us within the kin
the customs union avoid this kind of
obsession
you know that the government have this
obsession that the European Court of
Justice shouldn't be involved that you
know the practical consequence of this
is that very good arrangements you know
you Ratan
that does excellent research based in
the UK around things like cancer
research this could be destroyed because
of this obsession with some red lines
which have been dreamt up by the
militant tendency in the Conservative
Party this is very damaging I want to
pin you down a bit on what your policy
is on brexit because you've said that
you want to try and remain in the single
market you've also previously said about
free movement of people having to be
changed or coming to an end I mean that
sounds a little bit like Boris Johnson
might say have cake eat cake policy over
the eve of you didn't well I I do
believe in the principle of the free
movement of labour and indeed Lee the
four principles of the single market but
actually if you look at the way the
European Union works other member
countries have some degree of restraints
on movement I'm in a morgue let me just
give you death just give an example
which I dealt with when I was in
government the Germans say you cannot
just freely go into Germany unless you
have a German professional qualification
which is why we don't have free trade in
services and it's that kind of practical
pragmatic step working within the
European Union we're working within the
single market respecting the principles
that's the kind of outcome we should be
looking at instead of this sort of
grandstanding that the British
government has adopted that you're
either completely 100 percent in or you
have to leave the whole thing and that's
what's causing this enormous disastrous
move into this hard brexit that's doing
so much damage you see I was still a
little bit confused by this that's
having a look now at something you said
a week after the referendum which is
there should be some control over
migration from the EU this will however
make it difficult to retain single
market status so if you accepted that
then what's changed to understand it is
difficult but they can be reconciled and
I've just the court to retain single
market status well I think actually when
you when you reflect on it and I've
reflected on it it is perfectly possible
to reconcile these things because other
member states do this you've changed
since then well that was put in a rather
stark terms I think it is absolutely
possible to remain within the single
market to respect the principle of
freedom of movement that to have some
degree of management of migration other
countries do it we should do it and
you're not just playing so your Lib Dem
audience here no I believe in this stuff
and I I'm I've been you know fighting
for the European Union and British
membership for half a century I'm very
committed to the project and I think my
part is in exactly the right position
representing a very very large swathe of
public opinion that is becoming very
alarmed the way in which this hard
brexit option is be pursued not just by
the Conservatives but by jeremy corbyn's
Labour Party and they do want an
alternative but when we see the economic
pain kicking in more and more people are
going to want an alternative and we're
the only party operator she'll give you
a trivial example this week swindled on
this is being launched and the people
who normally produce the strawberries
can't produce them because the labor
force has disappeared because of anxiety
about their future status in Britain and
that's one of hundreds and hundreds of
practical examples of the way in which
this extreme form of brexit is going to
harm Britain and we've got to stop it
and I'm interested to know your thoughts
on your predecessor Tim Farron who of
course led the Lib Dems through a
difficult election campaign he was came
under a lot of scrutiny for some of his
views on things such as gay sex abortion
and so on that's why he resigned
according to his statement now let's
have a look at what one of your former
senior mp's David Laws said about Tim
Farron and which was as a gay man I do
not wish to be tolerated I wish to be
respected for who I am if that's one of
your own former MP saying that how much
damage do you think Tim Cohen's comments
did to the election campaign in the Lib
Dems well David Laws was very close
colleague man I'm enormous respect for
him and I think he said exactly the
right thing but I'm not criticising Tim
Farron them and he did a great job in
helping the party to recover from a
terrible
2015 situation built up a credible
position on Europe which is now put as
in a very strong position built upon
membership built up our activist base he
did as he himself acknowledged not
handled that whole issue very well of
reconciling his own personal faith with
his public positions on gay rights and
other issues and it's a perfect his
position was a perfectly fair one you
know a lot of people have private views
deriving from their religion but they
have to put these on one side when
they're in acting public policy and he
acknowledged that he hadn't got that
right though and that's you know why he
stood down but I very much respect him
he did too Trebek job for the party
and I respect his personal faith I mean
I'm not suggesting for a moment he
should give that up okay so if instead
cable thank you very much for coming on
the show this morning